thank you very much martin hello
everyone welcome to the
north east arborshall district council's
meeting of the cabinet
it's the 22nd of april uh 2021
and with me in the room there are
various cabinet members as well as
senior officers uh with responsibility
for some of the items on the agenda
today
so we'll get started uh straight away
it's
first item is apologies for absence um
alan received chair received and just to
record
karen hanson's absence uh and apologies
for that okay
um declarations of interest uh
any declarations for any members to
declare
no okay uh minute to the last meetings
uh on the 28th of january and the 18th
of february
um are there any uh any matters of
accuracy that anyone wishes to
uh would you use to query
no if not can i have a mover and a
seconder
thank you and seconded by councillor
parking thank you very much all those in
favor
okay they're approved thank you very
much and then we come
to the uh item four which is the medium
term
financial plan uh budget monitoring
paper so i'll hand over to
councillor parking just to uh talk us
through the the highlights of this
thank you very paper chair um right
essentially this is a a budget monitor
the report is uh to update cabinet and
the public of course
uh on the current financial position of
the
council as uh as during that period
so um this this is uh the third
quarter's budget monitoring exercise for
the general fund
uh the housing revenue account and of
course the capital program
and copy 19 pandemic is
inevitably uh having a detrimental
impact on the council's
financial position and the main
company's income loss from
fees and charges and mainly within
leisure services but also within other
services such as
not testing and commercial waste as
demonstrated
in the table at 2.1 in the report
as far as the general fund is concerned
appendices one and two
summarize the general fund position and
as you'd expect uh having recently
reviewed the budget there are
a few variances to report in q3
um which and
there is an analysis in there about
345 000 pound variants uh pay budgets
have begun to accrue
so uh they total 173
uh thousand pounds and there are a few
variances in
and services as costs have swung
up and down and the main
the main variance in is in income and
this is
mainly because planning fees have
exceeded
pre-covered levels this year which is
excellent
um well done planning uh and
um as far as the hra is concerned
appendix 3 provides the details for that
there are very few variances to note
on the hra and it's fair to say that the
hra has remained stable throughout
the pandemic uh from a financial
perspective
a capital program is summarized in
appendix 4
and details of the capital expenditure
incurred
on a scheme by scheme basis um
pausing the capital approval program
earlier in
the year 2020 has limited the amount of
capital works
during the first half of the year so
things are relevant
three quarter three um
so uh yeah i think that's
pretty much it for uh for my comments
um i think uh
are there any questions on that okay
thanks council marketing
um jane is there anything to add to what
paul said okay thank you chair only to
say that it's obviously going to be
superseded by out 10 in the coming weeks
i think this report's been somewhat
delayed because of unscheduled
cancellations
and so it is a little bit untimely um
but we will be bringing the out term
report
very soon next month or so hopefully
okay any questions or comments on the
report
if not uh council parking are you happy
to move the recommendations
sure i'll move the recommendation in six
uh 6.1 which um
which is uh about the cabinet noting the
budget monitoring position as outlined
in this
report and its appendices okay thanks
for that i'm happy to second
uh and all those in favor
brilliant thank you very much uh and
then the next item is the
uh performance monitoring uh report so
i'm gonna hand over to
uh kath drury to just talk us through
the the key highlights of this paper
that's okay
are you just on muker
right okay i'm with you now similar to
jane uh this reports a little bit out of
time as well with it being for q3 so
it's covering the period october to
december
and we are currently just starting to
report on q4 so there will be a report
coming to cabinet
uh soon regarding q4 update so covering
this report then
uh you can see on the summary page that
uh 45 of the targets are on track
uh so that's the 61 which is
uh which is good 21 targets remain
affected by cobalt and they're the
similar suite of targets that we've been
reporting
on so the ones that are clearly affected
by kirbys such as ledger attendancies
and anything that we call
the call requires face-to-face
uh intervention so obviously those
targets remain
affected until the restrictions start to
lift a couple of targets have been
achieved this time
and we've got a couple that are overdue
and i'll just cover those under the
the aims further in the report so
um under the economy aim the target that
was overdue is eco
20 and that's review resources to ensure
tourism is the focus of the economic
development team
i'm aware that reports coming to the
next cabinet meeting so this should be
signed off at that
point it's obviously been delayed with
the other restructures in this area so
that's now progressing and will be
done and dusted very soon and under the
environment one and
target number five as we've been
reporting for a while and as members are
aware
playing enforcement's had particular
difficulties this year with not having
enough resource
so they've not done the proactive
exercises that they would like to do i
know
the planning manager has got some things
in mind once he's got the resource in
place and i think the enforcement
manager is due to start in july but
obviously they are doing proactive
planning enforcement work when things
come to their attention
through members or the public so they
are obviously doing
some level of enforcement but they're
not doing exercises they want to
initiate themselves so
hopefully that'll start to pick up in
the next financial year when the
resource is in place
and there's a few more there that have
been achieved this time
and the same under residence another one
that's been achieved that's been signed
off
and then under services uh the one
that's overdue there is review the
council's petition scheme
uh by uh full council last year and
that's
going to be rolled forward to this
year's work kind of sort of
extension from from sarah sternberg so
we'll put that forward
to extend this target in the next
cabinet meeting so there's been work on
that discussions behind the scenes and
now we've got a firmer foot into that
target going forward
so not a you know overall quite a decent
picture there's lots of activity going
forward and
all the details in the appendix where
the full listing
of the council targets are there
okay thanks
uh any comments or questions from any
cabinet members then
no uh i'll happily uh move the report
then
are there any is there a seconder
charlotte thank you
kenton cupid all those in favor
okay thanks very much uh and then we
come
to the biggie which is the uh grow
strategy
um so i'll hand over to uh council
renick uh
just talking through this one he said
thank you chair
obviously northeast africa district
council plan show the importance of
economic growth strategy for the
well-being and prosperity of the
district and as you know we've been
working on this for over 12 months and
of course
the pandemic came and we decided to
switch to a
recovery plan uh we've been working
through that so now it's a
good opportunity now to refine the
growth plan
it's still in draft format i have to say
because we still have the
assets and investment strategy to add to
this
uh which talks a little bit about our
assets how we manage those and
indeed industrial retail units that we
also manage
um and the the paper you've got probably
isn't the latest paper but we
um we have rather than the vision of not
on offer that northeast derbyshire is a
business friendly
district where businesses are nurtured
to grow and thrive
and this council and its partners will
endeavor to provide guidance assistance
facilities support
these businesses and that's as for the
actual
um strategy itself you know we we very
much aligned to the um
government's industrial strategy of
building a britain fit for the future
this is the white paper that sets out
the government's plan for
transforming the economy and bringing
about new growth and there's
five foundations in the government's
white paper and that's
censors around ideas being innovative
people you know good jobs and earning
power for all which fits into the skills
gender infrastructure you know major
great upgrade to our infrastructure
physical and digital and the business
environment
being the best place start and grow
business and you know we need to sell
the benefits of um having a visiting
northeast derbyshire district
council area and places um prosperous
communities across
our district which is the sort of place
regeneration that we're also involved
with
in the tip and there's also grand
challenges set by the government which
puts a knot into the data economy
digital economy
to clean growth making sure we maximize
um the advantages of the uk and for our
district
from a global shift to clean growth and
also
future mobility in an aging society so
with that in mind the priority areas for
the
the growth strategy for the district is
business support and engagement
it's employment skills we've already
seen the skills
uh paper come to this cabinet which is
being signed off
as well as the vista economy strategy uh
town center regeneration as you know
we've been very fortunate to be
awarded 24 million pounds from the
government
to the town investment and that's a huge
coup for this for this district we're
open for business
and that subsidy center stage is part of
our growth strategy
and of course we want to do more for the
rest of the towns and high streets in
our district
we also have an inward investment to
tackle um
that will come about particularly around
the clay cross investment plan because
obviously we need to
garner as much support and capital and
investment from outside sources
we have a major science development uh
plan
coming forward soon in terms of the
sites that we've already got some that
we're working on already some that
might need a re-look at and then also
we've got
you know we are living in a royal
agricultural economy with brexit we do
need to
to make sure we support all areas of our
um
of our district so with these in place
um
we we also need to make sure that
there's three cross-cutting themes
and the use of low carbon technology
it's the
increased development of digital
solutions and equality and diversity so
making sure that our growth plan
for this district includes all
so lastly then this is a draft
the will obviously there's a lot of um
of the action points in if you look
at the end of the report there's a list
of all the uh
of all the actual actions some of them
are well underway
about to start but i just wanted to
update the cabinet and i will be
updating full council on monday and for
really just to
um i'd like to make recommendations that
you note the complex report
and the growth strategy and also that
there's some dedicated authority given
to me
and to our director of growth and
economic development just to refine it
as when the assets and investment
strategy comes in line
and other little areas that we're
working on to
make this document complete any
questions
okay thanks carol any other comments or
questions from from cabinet members
uh uh council parking yeah thank you i
i can see a lot of work into this
capital and
and i would like to uh congratulate you
on the
on the output the albeit draft and
i think uh i'm looking forward to the
time when it
all comes together in one cohesive paper
and we can
and we can move forward with it thank
you yes
thank you and yes absolutely thanks to
uh
to all our officers um we're a small
small team um and actually a lot of
work's been produced as you know from
the recovery plan
you know we have some 40-hour projects
ongoing
and um this is the product of some of
these
coming together now and a vision and an
ambition
to do more to make sure that you know
this is a good friendly district
business place and i think um with the
assets investment strategy added to this
um and a bit of help from finance
um we will have a good case making
um but we're making a case for being
one of the one of the best places in the
in derbyshire
to start and grow a business thank you
thanks thanks councilman um yeah just to
echo what uh council parking said
obviously thank you to all the
all the team and the staff who've worked
so hard on this um
just to highlight as well i think that
it's been through uh growth scrutiny and
it
had sort of pretty universal praise from
uh from across the board which is very
very pleasing um obviously as you said
there's some other documents that sit uh
behind it or underneath it and
and some more to come as well so look
forward to seeing how it how it develops
over a period of time but from my
perspective it's
really pleasing to see that it covers
such a broad
uh range um in terms of the economy in
in
in north east arbor i know previous
growth strategies that the district have
had have largely basically been housing
growth strategies not not gross
strategies so i think it's really
pleasing to see that we've got a you
know a broader range and a proper plan
to how we want to
uh grow the local economy in north
establishes so i'm very pleased to see
it
i'm assuming you've you've uh proposed
it carolyn so i'll i'll second
uh and move to the vote to all those in
favor
okay thank you for that that's carried
uh and then we come to item uh item
seven which is
urgent items and there are none
uh and then item eight is the exclusion
of the
of the public so thank you to everyone
who's who's joined us
and and look forward to hopefully seeing
you soon but at this stage i will move
that the public be excluded from the
meeting
during the discussion of the following
items of business to avoid the
disclosure
to them of exempt information as defined
in part one
of schedule 12 a to the local government
act 1972
as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006.
thank you very much if we can end the
live stream
you